now look what they're doing they're
purposefully trying to get Kovac because
they know they're gonna get let go check
out this story California sheriff's
sheriff says inmates tried to infect
themselves with coronavirus two groups
of inmates inmates at a Los Angeles
County Jail this is a different story
right no no this is LA okay I think this
LA or the same story I think so they
tried to infect themselves by sharing
water in a mask okay and within two
weeks 30 prisoners tested positive
Sheriff Alex Villanueva at a briefing
showed surveillance videos from two
dormitory units at the North County
Correctional Facility in Castaic yeah
okay the same place the footage captured
inmates in one unit sharing a container
of hot water and others in a second unit
sniffing so gross
let me slip that mattiro amen you got
masks I got mass oh good positive I'd
like to go home yeah my goodness the
footage captures inmates in one unit
Chang a container over that the sheriff
said the inmates used hot water to try
to raise their temperatures just before
a nurse checked them an elevated
temperature is a symptom for coronavirus
Villanueva's that the inmates mistakenly
believed that if they were infected they
would be freed it's dismaying and it's
disheartening
none of the 30 inmates required critical
care when they were sick though some had
moderate symptoms said Bruce chase the
department's assistant sheriff of
custody operations no prisoners within
the county's jail system the largest in
the country have died from the virus
jails and prisons nationwide have become
flashpoints more than 25 thousand
inmates have been infected and about 350
of diagnosing one from Rikers Island in
New York to federal state and local law
ops lockups coast to coast according to
unofficial tally kept by The Cove in
nineteen behind bars data project run by
UCLA law in California five inmates in a
state prison in San Bernardino have died
from kovat complications and outbreaks
so we got this they say in in LA County
in mid-april the North County
Correctional Facility didn't have a
single case days later nine inmates were
flagged as being potentially sick I
don't know if California has actually
ended up releasing anybody so well I'll
wrap this one up they say for for most
people the corona virus cases are mild
or moderate we know this fever cough got
yata for some it's all there okay we get
it
so the inmates think they're gonna get
released yeah we're because
this is California they're not letting
you go yeah not in California not Texas
or New York right why would you let
people go you think sex is the place
where they're like son you got Kovan so
we're giving you the chair
yeah just line them up wasn't a cool
beverage yeah
crank him in crank them out but they
they still hey everybody hold hands
do they still hang people in Texas I
don't think so what no they don't they
definitely on the death penalty there
yeah Texas yeah haven't hung people for
years yeah I'm pretty sure that there
was a state that still hanged people
what yeah I was kidding about Texas we
love Texas but Texas you'd think would
be substantially more brutal in terms of
like keeping people locked up not
letting them go and then arresting a
salon owner that's not yeah that doesn't
make sense
but it gets better it gets better well
we gotta set examples for those those
salon owners that think they can open up
everything we got us we gotta set that
example man or you also had in Texas I
mean you do have some hardcore people
those those dudes showing up with the
you know with with rifles yeah at the
bar big boys a Big Daddy right Big Daddy
things right and then and then the the
police send out that big Bearcat or
whatever it's called huh huh things are
getting spicy man this is nuts what are
they doing check out this story though
prisoner released from facilities to
limit kovat 19 spread arrested again for
crimes now this is Everett Washington oh
my good they say commie borg is a
business owner in Everett and she knew
this was inevitable it puts everybody at
risk he could have broken into our store
instead police say Matthew Cruz enraged
on a Thai restaurant across the street
on Broadway amped up on methamphetamines
using a crowbar to smash the wooden
boards I'm sure glad they released this
man from jail what's let me ask you
something listen we do have an ethical
conundrum here what are the moral
constraints of a society when it comes
to locking someone up where they could
potentially be infected with a deadly
disease like is that is that ethical is
that moral is that constitutional it
might border on cruel and unusual
punishment yeah telling someone straight
up I know that you mug that old woman
and you
getting a year in jail also there's a
viral contagion with a you know moderate
mortality rate according to recent
estimates that could mess you up do we
as a society have a right to put someone
in the position that's a tough question
man I don't know that's why I understand
tor understand and lean towards I like
letting people out mm-hmm but they got
to do better vetting like this guy
what's the first thing he does he takes
a bunch of meth and then goes and
smashes windows with a crowbar like but
we keep how many how many times we read
stories like this mm-hmm this is like
what the fourth or fifth all I could
think of as the the birdshot buckshot
birdshot buckshot Oh Dave Chappelle he
gets up it's he's unfazed but think
about what's like all this that's
happening and now it's like okay we're
gonna arrest Ilan we're gonna release
criminals or not everybody go I think
this is a major catalyst for the
Boogaloo man I think so too
it's funny vice wrote about the the
Boogaloo boys the Boogaloo movement it's
like calm down Vice you're looking for
everything everywhere I do think we're
dangerously close to a civil war I don't
know I don't I don't know what that
means
right I could just be a little excited
I've been saying this for a while now
but I but I haven't been wrong a little
fear-mongering no no no no no no someone
like you fear-mongering would be me
lying and trying to claim something so
that I could drum up clicks or something
okay me telling you my legit opinion on
what's been going out of the past
several years and where we at today ANCA
that's not for your mongering sure some
people will say it is for sure criticize
me but I'm being completely legit when
I'm asking these questions yeah cuz
listen a bunch of dudes showed up to a
grocery store they're wearing masks they
have body armor they have rifles totally
legal mm-hmm total eagle now you had a
bunch people show up to this bar that
was defying the governor orders the
governor's orders and then the Bearcat
comes out technically still totally
legal right because inside the store I
thought it's not even that the governor
does have the right to decree that you
can't write you know do these things
it's like now now when it comes to
business licenses there's an argument
there but we're still getting
dangerously close then you look at
prisons letting people out judges
telling them
to apologize to me apologize now or else
and she was like nope but I'm not even
applaud that woman yeah say that I was
like but here's here's the important bit
the Supreme Court of Texas overturned it
meaning we were always on the side of
the law when we said she should not
submit and apologize right and the
Supreme Court overruled the lower court
so we and everybody who said this woman
was doing the right thing was correct
yep the scary thing is you'd get banned
from social media because you know they
don't care yeah okay you can't say these
things but I'll tell you what right now
we're not we won't get super political
but I got good I'm gonna I'm gonna throw
it Obama gave in to the Knicks on this
one oh man Obama gave Obama gate and
then we'll come heard him say we'll
bring it back to the on-the-ground stuff
and the boogaloo stuff listen men right
now you've got Donald Trump tweeting at
Obama gate mm-hmm the implication that
Obama directed or was involved in false
charges brought against Trump
administration to sabotage his
administration as he was coming into
power it seems like it but it's beyond
that it's that there's a lot of
insinuations about you know was the
previous administration involved in
trying to sabotage the campaign of Trump
to help Hillary win beyond that why do
we go through years of this conspiracy
theory stuff yeah so I'm don't get it
need to get too much into that because
you know I want to keep it to the on the
ground stuff but this is where it brings
us today you've got right now documents
being released from you know the
Attorney General and you know classified
documents and conservatives are pretty
much on board with it looks like there's
something dirty here from the Obama
administration for sure at the very
least Obama knew and we don't know how
he knew this stuff was going on and it
was it's like it's crazy the FBI went
after Michael Flynn's kid they had no
justification for investing him in the
first place they took one casual
statement he made and claimed it was a
lie during an investigation and use that
to prosecute him so all this gets
overturned you have two factions right
now you have the left that believes
Donald Trump is subverting the rule of
law okay and that he's he's a mobster
getting all his buddies off the hook for
crimes that committed then you have
another faction that believes the Obama
administration and the FBI were falsely
laying charges to sabotage Trump's
administration and now finally Trump is
on the counter-offensive weeding out the
corrupt
it doesn't matter what you think is
right the fact is they exist so what
happens when Trump gets re-elected or
what happens when this goes when stuff
like this what's happening so to bring
it back to the on-the-ground stuff you
have in the debate about to whether or
not to reopen or stay closed tribalism
the left doesn't care about the science
they don't care about the facts they
don't care about the studies they don't
care about the UN they don't care about
the starvation they're saying shut up
and shut down period yep that's scary
it's true so what it is it's spreading
people into two factions it's like open
up or not to open up I think the
objective not the objective reality is
that we can see real wrongdoing on the
part of these FBI agents definitely
Obama knew we'll see how far that goes
I'm not gonna make I know a lot of
people don't a lot of research in this
will make more definitive claims about
the Obama administration but it stands
to reason that right now the evidence
shows the right is it's like correct
liens in their direction especially when
you look at what's going on to lock down
his work at things get crazy
first of all governors don't have the
right to decree that you can't protest
Bill de Blasio has no right to decree it
you can't protest mm-hmm so so the left
is already in the wrong on this one
absolutely UN says starvation is coming
we got a reopen what does the Left say
people want haircuts just not true
that's not what people are protesting
for now some people for sure but to
highlight the one person under the you
know hundreds of thousands yeah it makes
no we're seeing surfers in California in
Hawaii be like no way dude like insane
lies from people that the virus is
vaporized in the ocean shore and it'll
get you sick if you go near it like this
and it's nuts yeah it doesn't make any
sense but then they come they come out
and they argue that the right is anti
science and Elon Musk is anti science
they arbitrarily say Elon Musk can't
reopen wait the right says that the left
okay yeah yeah so the red I was like I
said right yeah I was like what the left
is arguing that you you know you can't
reopen whatever yes stupid so if you
look at what's actually going on with
the data that we have we're four or five
studies now saying the mortality rate is
very very very low and we they're
they're substantially more people who
have had this we've had local doctors
come out get their videos deleted from
YouTube and you know for calling this
out you know the UN says if we don't
reopen 130 million will starve I think
at the very least we can say we get it
it's serious you know people
their lives right more people are gonna
lose their lives because the economy is
collapsing exactly we've got to get
things going again so people can get
food and get but they don't they don't
care yeah people can go out just wear
masks
wash your hands social distance we can
do this people aren't idiots we can we
can make it happen
peope well it reminds me that men in
black comment right person is smart okay
people are dumb panicky you know
dangerous dangerous animals as that was
the quote I love that yeah it's a good
quote but an individual who doesn't want
to get sick right right if you want to
go to Walmart you see someone not
wearing a mask
you avoid them that's true you walk away
you wear gloves you sanitize your hands
don't touch your face
there are ways you could protect
yourself but we also know the data has
shown going outside is actually better
sixty-six percent of people who have
gotten sick have we're staying home I
think this was in New York showing that
the people who are going out
consistently were less likely to get
sick so the lockdown may have failed
something happen
last the lockdown may have may have been
substantially may have hurt us more so
so we have all this data now it's time
to reassess what do we get you know
tribalism saying no so I just think
about what happens come November Vegas
odds have Trump to win the polls had
Biden to win but they're dropping is
crazy
there's a really funny tweet I saw where
a bunch of Bernie supporters were
laughing when the balls came that Trump
was now beating Biden in a bunch of key
states yeah so it's like what happens
when you have all of this all of these
people who are betrayal II want the
lockdowns to continue jokingly saying
fine going arrest Elon Musk attacking
Elon Musk even though he's completely in
the right you know and then Trump wins
again do these people just say like well
gosh darn it we lost I guess we'll just
carry on with our lives
I don't know it feels like they're
becoming a minority like I don't know
anybody like that anymore and all my
friends who used to like Bernie don't
really yeah follow Bernie anymore
they're becoming more I say conservative
but they're they're not conservative but
they sure don't associate with Democrats
anymore the left side yeah nothing
everybody I know maybe maybe then what
we're really seeing is like the last
remnants of the Democratic establishment
call
saying see that makes more sense to me I
don't I don't think it's gonna be a
Boogaloo it's gonna be people are like
oh wait we all feel the same way all
right all right good well the few that
have that thought they had a huge voice
and a huge backing they're like suddenly
there's no one behind them and they're
just standing by themselves it's the
internet you know yes but I think maybe
one of the ways to look at it is the
Trump defeated the Republican
establishment okay crushed them they're
gone they've they've either fall in line
with Trump or they've retired and
they're gone they did it to themselves
more what do you mean
the Democrats know the Republicans
defeated the Republican establishment oh
okay yeah in 2015 2016 when he won right
we're gonna shut him out and then you
have the never Trump or Republicans go
oh whoa no will resist and then they
join the Democrats but now you have that
last vestige of the establishment
collapsing you've got the the leftist
populist smocking them and laughing as
they wither and and he same thing from
the right-wing populist like the O'Neal
the elite establishment is gone sure so
maybe and it's that's a good point I
don't think about it maybe there won't
be a Boogaloo because what we're really
seeing is the vocal the the last
remnants of a vocal minority shrinking
into into nothingness yep that's what I
that's what I see yes yeah
for the record he agreed with me yeah
everyone take everyone loves uh calling
out the other way but see there are
sometimes you're in agreement maybe
there will be no Boogaloo I don't think
there's gonna be a Boogaloo well cuz
Trump it is fun to say though it's from
an 80s movie how did it become the word
for civil war sounds weird sounds like a
really cool cat's name
oh that's Boogaloo he's cool he's cool